Oscar nominations are being announced
this morning as a matter of fact right
now Fandango's Fandango rather Eric
Davis is here to break them all down so
they're still coming in Eric but this is
what we have so far actress in a
supporting role and actor in a
supporting role Angela Bassett
black panther wakanda forever uh Hong
Chow from The Whale Carrie Condon from
the Banshees Jamie Lee Curtis and
everything everywhere all at once
Stephanie Shu everything everywhere all
at once my apologies if I mispronounce
anybody's name but the big story here so
far to me seems Angela Bassett because
she'd be the first Marvel person who's
ever been nominated sure big those Black
Panther movies doing wonders for Marvel
right now in terms of like the best that
you know in terms of these big Oscars
but yeah Angela Bassett nominated in
1994 almost 30 years ago and yeah she's
been winning this category at a lot of
other Awards I think there's a
Groundswell of support for her I'm
rooting for her I think she deserves it
everybody else in that category is a
first timer so it's that is nice to see
even Jamie Lee Curtis as a veteran is
the first first timer yeah okay actor in
a supporting role Brendan Gleason in the
Banshees uh Brian Tyree Henry I know him
from uh Atlanta he was great in that
yeah Judd Hirsch and the Fable men's uh
Barry Keegan yeah from the Banshees also
and Ki Wang Juan he's already won the
Golden Globe everything everywhere all
at once yeah Key's story is my favorite
mine tooth season here's a guy you know
well known as a kid for starring in
Indiana Jones and the Goonies then
Hollywood forgets about him just doesn't
doesn't typically yeah it doesn't work
he's working as like an uncredited stunt
guy in the early 2000s but stays with it
keeps the dream alive perseveres finds
his way to this he was so good in this
film awesome in this in this film I
think he's going to win best supporting
actor an Oscar I mean just this is like
the Hollywood Story the quintessential
Hollywood Story and also Judd Hirsch
look at him last night in 1981 similar
to Angela Bassett like all of these
years later he gets his second
nomination it's that's really great and
he's in a small role in the Fable men's
video it was a sweet moment at the
Golden Globes with key with Steven
Spielberg when from the podium he said
thank you so much Stephen Spielberg and
then you see him as that little boy in
Indiana Jones you know instantly who he
is yeah is he the odds on favorite as we
sit here today in your mind I would say
he's the favorite yeah and it's funny
the first call that he got after
everything everywhere came out uh well
at once came out was from Kevin feige
from Marvel saying we want to put you in
a Marvel thing so he's going to star in
the second season of Loki uh which comes
out later this year all right well we
have an exclusive announcement we have
the best actor nominations Austin Butler
Elvis of course I think we expected that
Colin Farrell uh banshees we have the
well Paul mascale and uh after sun
um oh Brendan Frazier in the world
excuse me Palmer scale after sun and
Bill Nye
um living all first time nominees really
yeah Paul muscal getting in there is a
surprise I really think this is going to
be between Colin Farrell Brendan Frazier
and Austin Butler I think honestly it's
going to be Austin Butler you do if you
look at Brendan over Brendan I think
it's in gonna be Brenda you know what
Elvis Presley himself never nominated
for an Oscar and I believe this is the
first time ever that a performance of
Elvis is nominated for a best performing
Oscar and then you have the there's
extra weight to his nomination with the
recent death of Lisa Marie Presley so
but the voting was done don't you think
already yeah the voting's already in for
the nominee well for the nomination we
have to vote for the final round of
voting yeah but I think it's a great
story and funny if Austin Butler wins
he'll be the first uh best actor winner
that was born in the 1990s yeah
he was great in it but everybody keeps
talking about the Renaissance for
Brendan they do it's a big deal it's a
big deal for Brendan Fraser and he's
fantastic in the film but look at what
he's up against Elvis Presley you know
and I just like when you think of Elvis
Presley and Austin Butler
Lisa Marie Presley also exactly yeah it
just really adds to it so I think I
think this is Austin's year and he's
such a great guy so we have best picture
rolling in here and as we run out of
time I just want to go we get All Quiet
on the west in front Avatar
banshees of insurance Elvis everything
everywhere
all at once fableman's tar Top Gun Top
Gun
nominated there's 10 in this category
triangle of sadness and women talking
black panther was not nominated for
business I do not see it on this list
and I did not hear it in my ear juice
now these are just coming out but if
that's 10 then no it was not does that
surprise you that black panther wasn't
apparent a little bit of a surprise but
this is the story right Avatar Elvis Top
Gun big Studio Hollywood making a
comeback remember Apple won best picture
last year for Coda this year or maybe
All Quiet on the Western Front maybe the
only streaming movie nominated but
normally these big epic pictures that do
so well at the box office
typically don't win the Oscar do you
think that could be different it could
be people say that Top Gun might have a
huge shot I think it's so because of the
preferential ballot you know a lot of
people are going to be putting it in its
top three uh and I think top gun
Maverick has a shot it's great to see
commercial Fair big Studio Hollywood
coming back to the best picture race and
I think that you know the academy has
been criticized over the last few years
for not recognizing these films that a
lot of people are going to see it in
they love but it's so different I mean I
have I have actress in a leading role
while you're here Kate Blanchett and
Tarr Anna dearmus and blonde uh Andrea
riseborough
yes Michelle Williams of fable men's
that's not a surprise and Michelle yo
everything everywhere all at once wow
the Andrea risborough this is a film too
Leslie actually just watched it on a
plane she's fantastic it's on the plane
yeah she's playing a recovering addict
uh who's trying to reunite with her
estranged son but there was a
Groundswell of support for her right at
the last minute and they actually made
it happen and got her in there so that
to me best surprise of the morning but
Michelle has been Michelle yo has been
running away with everything she has
used to be between her and Kate Lynch I
think it's yeah ultimately I think it's
between Michelle and Cate Blanchette I'm
hoping Michelle yo wins first time
nominee brilliant in everything
everywhere I mean look Kate's a legend
yeah like no doubt but I think Michelle
yo deserves I can't wait for Oscar night
I love the awesome big smile on his face
thank you Eric thank you very much